just three years ago all the Klimenko
barely knew anything about tuberculosis
that is until a routine check-up changed
her life we can't know how many people
around us have TB many just don't know
their status yet but even after her
recovery the fear of reinfection is
never far away
there was a time I couldn't make myself
get on public transport
I just couldn't we were all doing it
whether we're coughing sneezing or just
breathing out each of us is constantly
exhaling thousands of tiny liquid
droplets droplets that can spread the
common cold but also tuberculosis that's
what makes it such a feared disease I
was praying that it was cancer anything
but TB when I got that diagnosis it felt
like my life was over I packed my things
Hospital and said goodbye to my friends
that is the friends who stuck by me lots
of people had just disappeared from my
life that happens to everyone who gets
TB all her takes us to a closed hospital
for TB patients on the edge of the
capital Kiev visiting the patients even
for just a couple of minutes means
taking extensive precautions since her
own recovery all hers dedicated herself
to fighting for better care for
Ukraine's tuberculosis patients we head
to the most secure part of the hospital
my sill is 68 and has multi-resistant TB
standard antibiotic treatment isn't
enough to beat the strains of the
disease he carries he too only
discovered he was infected by chance we
had a routine checkup at work they took
an x-ray and found a problem I had no
symptoms at all
I didn't realize anything was wrong
Versalles treatment will take longer and
his chances of a full recovery are lower
than for those patients with
conventional strains of TB more than a
quarter of TB cases seen in Ukraine and
multi-resistant that's one of the
highest incidences worldwide experts say
that's down too many
patience not completing their course
medication and a health system that
confined patients in close quarters
allowing them to infect one another we
join over on the children's ward many of
these children were infected by their
parents here in hospital they have
little in the way of distractions and no
school while recent years have seen big
improvements in the medicines available
to patients in Ukraine although worries
that's not enough people with
tuberculosis need help they need support
it's not just about the drugs a lot
depends on patient's emotional state
whether or not they'll complete their
course of medication and whether or not
they'll make a full recovery
Wein you're doing way more than Buddha
on the kata